i just want to start with congrats on
the movie uh it's fantastic
as usual you're both great in it and
that's all i have i'm out
i'll see you guys later take care buddy
okay
i love it i love it i love it took the
picture and left
thank you um so listen i'm a huge fan of
soderbergh you guys have both worked
with him uh before
uh what do you think would surprise
people to learn
about the making of a soda berg movie
uh it's brevity um
the that he's he's he's fast
um he's succinct um but you don't feel
like
you're missing anything i think when you
go from a stevens
soderberg movie and work on other
projects i i know anyway
oftentimes i'm like why are we spending
six and seven hours to
get you know this two-page scene you
know that
you feel like there's a lot of
meandering and people like trying to
figure stuff out and stephen just kind
of knows what he wants and he comes in
and he's like
this is all i need you guys give that to
me and then boom we move on
uh and uh it takes a minute before you
can trust
that that you really have done what you
needed to do and that he really knows
but then you see the end product you're
like oh yeah i guess he really didn't
know
i also it's really
interesting to watch him work in between
setups because
he's working he's really working it out
you know he's not just like oh yeah
this is what i know he grinds and uh and
that's really interesting
his process is not simple
and uh and it's nice to see because as i
think as actors we're like
all kind of like uh
thinking about the next scene that
you're doing or the next setup and uh
and you're kind of you you got to keep a
constant your concentration level has
got to be
there but some you know i i remember
looking at stephen and he's equally as
concentrated and like cheatle
uh said he will get you home early
you know he will it will be very
efficient
he's he goes from point a to point b and
he ain't
he ain't going around it's just going a
to b a to b
and that and that's once you know that
it's it's a pleasure to
work with him like that and you trust
him you trust him when he goes like
hey i got it and you go like are you
sure and he goes yeah i got it
it's so interesting because soda bird
works so fast and has these amazing
results
and fincher works so slow on set and has
these amazing results
it's like polar opposite but they're
both brilliant filmmakers
correct yeah you know um so one of the
other things i want to talk about is uh
ed solomon's script is
fantastic i love the way that it works
in the real world events
while also you know with these small
time criminals for both of you what did
you respond to with the script what are
you excited for people to see
well i think one of the the most amazing
parts about it really is
the postscript you know the the the the
outro
where you learn uh of what this script
was really
kind of designed around you know i think
people will be uh
interested or surprised to realize that
this was kind of a reverse
engineered story um to to get that
postscript in you know that it was about
telling people about what the industry
was like what happened with car
companies then
um and what it was doing to the
neighborhoods around it you know in
in certain ways it's like chinatown you
know uh when you're
when you find out about the invention of
without giving the movie away what
you know the what the center piece of
this this whole thing is what all this
drama is around
um that it's historically accurate and
that ed
and steven kind of built the story
around that to smuggle that in
so you're like when you think about it
it was designed in that way like wow he
made a whole movie
you know around this point and created
these characters
to tell a story about this thing to
smuggle that information in
and it's a super entertaining and fun
and
great actors and so again a testament to
his mastery as a filmmaker
the roller coaster of the of these
the plot of the story and uh
all these different ways of lying you
know all these different
different different uh lies
from different characters and uh how
everyone is lying to an extent you know
that was that was really interesting how
it was put together
orchestrated on the script and it was
really interesting
you can lie with a smile you can lie
with a yell
you can you can lie with you know
minimal
in a minimal way you know everyone is
lying to an extent
you know to survive again congrats huge
fan of both of your works
uh work uh have a fantastic day okay you
stay there but then there's no war
machine
behind you on the shelf that's cool
that's all right bro bro it's cool
don't worry about it it's fine right i
have one over there